c'est une page plutôt méconnu du château
de versailles
après un pâle et un lieu d'habitation le
domaine devient musée ouvert à tous les
publics
le roi louis-philippe veut partager à
ses contemporains l'histoire de france
c'est la fabrique de l'histoire lui fini
qu'il fabrique notre histoire
d'aujourd'hui avec des différents
épisodes différents chapitres alors
après on peut les commenter les juger
mais lui nous livre comme l'a dit victor
hugo il ouvre le livre de l'histoire de
france pour nous inauguré en 1837 ce
château et pensé par le dernier
souverain avoir régné louis-philippe
transforme profondément le lieu il fait
aménager les appartements des courtisans
en galerie vous immerger dans les salles
qu'il a créé et donc vous voyez ce qu'il
a voulu faire du château de versailles
puisque vous découvrez 32 nouvelles
salles près de 5000 m² qui étaient des
sales qui n'était plus ouverte au public
ou pas toujours ouverte au public tels
que la salle des croisades qu'elle tels
que la grande galerie des batailles ou
tel que les salles d'afrique dans ses
salles des tableaux commandés des
oeuvres rapatriés par le monarque
l'exposition permet de découvrir
l'histoire avec un grand h
à travers celle personnelle d'un point